my audio version of the book is so for
the past number of weeks weeks weeks
I've been pounding my publisher saying
we need the audio version we need the
audio version we do people keep asking
for the audio version I gotta get it out
and I saw an order that came in this
morning from Carrie Lee who bought it on
audible and like wait a minute
audible doesn't mean it's up the other
version is up this is amazing I got so
excited the pole should even tell me
that it was up but it's up but at least
I'm audible and hopefully others as well
I'll double check that but the audible
link is now available and we'll put it
on the page so that you guys can be able
to buy it and the greater lesson here
for entrepreneurs is that I know isn't
always unknown this great clip that I
remember from Sylvester Stallone where
he said that he loved knows because I
know wasn't really know know was really
a yes challenge I really just I just
love I love it
you know I love being told no it just
means yes no and so quite often
entrepreneurs you're gonna get rejected
you're gonna get knows a lot and so you
need to keep on and keep on and keep on
it was something that you really believe
in something that you really love no
doesn't mean no no it's just a future
yes and you just waiting to get to that
yes and what really helped me was you
guys was showing the momentum is why I
reached out to you on the videos and
said hey if you want something from the
publisher put it in the comments and
what I kept doing to them was I screen
captured every time you wrote about the
audio version I would screen capture and
send another email and then another
email and another email so as they kept
getting bombarded with these requests
for the audio version and because it was
something that doesn't usually get done
that's the resistance and that's like it
wasn't that they hated me and they
didn't want that to happen for me it
just it just happened for anybody they
don't do pre releases of audiobooks it's
usually just released when the book gets
released and so I was asking to do
something that they don't typically do
and if it was just me asking and
pestering and asking then I might have
still got a yes but it's way easier to
show the momentum coming from you guys
and so that's super important whenever
you're trying to pitch a deal I remember
in venture capital business people would
come and pitch us ideas without getting
customers and said you know we're gonna
pass but they might come back six months
later and have customers and now we look
at that as a real potential opportunity
to invest into and so don't lose hope at
the first no but you have to do
something different you got to stay on
top of it you got to build momentum so
that you keep coming back to them with
something new showing greater and
greater greater momentum to hopefully
eventually get a yes so we got our yes
and it's thanks to you guys for helping
out so let's get to the questions let's
scroll through scroll through who do we
got who do we got some good questions
first up is Faisal Jay how about if they
forget what you did to them or dumb you
this is from my last video about how to
build connections I was saying you try
to add value to their lives you try to
look at everybody who is around you and
see how you can help them so that when
you need help they can make those
introductions for you first of all
expect it like it's gonna happen some
people will forget about you some people
won't remember what you did for them one
maybe what you did wasn't important
enough you know maybe it wasn't valuable
enough maybe they don't remember or care
because they don't remember that you did
that for them so that's on you to add
more value and be memorable
but regardless some people will never
reciprocate that's okay the reason to do
it isn't only to go and ask them for
something else right if that's the only
motive like I'm only doing this for you
so that you're gonna do something back
for me a minute later if that's the
incentive people can smell that people
can sense that it's not genuine the key
is enjoying that process like like
helping other people get to where they
want to go and net-net that always works
out because some people will never repay
it but the people who do repay it will
be worth way more than all the others
combined it's a classic you know venture
capital deal though they'll invest in
the tent companies that they all think
are gonna be winners but really one
company is gonna be a huge winner
most of the companies will fail or fall
short or won't get any revenue lose your
expectations but that one company out of
ten that they invest into does more than
all the others combined but going in you
don't know who that one of the ten is
gonna be you think they're all gonna be
the one but only one ends up actually
being the one so enjoy the process of
helping people make it part of something
that makes you come alive and if you can
ignore the outcome of only doing it to
help that other person like when I
mentioned what I was
it wasn't just to make the connections
is because I like helping people get to
where they want to go to and yes it's
great that there's a possibility that I
can win those connections back somehow
and it'll benefit me but it's not the
only reason to go in and doing it so yes
expect some people not to reciprocate
it's going to happen next up Tanika
Griffin thanks Evan simple no-nonsense
advice on how to build connections and
really preach the emphasis and adding
value to others but what can we do to
get Jason on camera Jason you're gonna
think about this what's happened what's
happened since last week still no way
what does Tanika have to do to get you
on camera nothing you're just going to
come impossible guys remember my talk of
the star to build momentum and not
accepting no one knows just yes we got
it we've got a we got to stay on Jason
he's smiling he secretly wants to do it
he's just afraid we got to keep the
comments coming for Jason show Jason
some love well we'll get him one of
these days on camera
next up Zeno brené Brown that name
sounds super familiar good I don't know
anything about her Renee is from Texas
and she speaks a lot about vulnerability
and how you should not be afraid to be
who you are and sometimes that means
you're gonna fail on a public stage and
it's it's a really personal message and
against it like fakty and make it kind
of mentality against like always win
kind of mentality and that she admits to
being scared before going out on say and
she admits to sharing insecurities about
herself and scenes like all these great
comments coming in one person comments
that she's fat or something and how that
makes her feel and that makes a really
strong human connection and so she has a
really great TED talk about
vulnerability that I would definitely
recommend checking out and so one of
these days I'm gonna find my path to get
to burn a brown just so that I can help
the person that I know in my business to
help her make that introduction I'd love
to meet Bernie but I'm not the kind of
person like there's nobody that I really
wish I could interview or meet I don't I
don't know I'm not that kind of person
but being able to do that for somebody
else really gets me excited so I'm gonna
make it happen one way or another it's
gonna happen next up Shelly Jason Jason
Jason would love to see Jason and he
loved to believe nation oh he's kind of
Shelley's got a rhyme
they're jason-- jason-- jason-- would
love to see Jason suddenly love to
believe nation 11 le we're working on it
Shelley Shelley see h-e-l-l-o why
Shelley I think chili I like the name
Jason Jason Jason he's smiling he's
smiling behind the camera maybe I'll
like secretly put a camera here
somewhere next time as you can see Jason
next up Peter could you do a top 10
super ease of success for John Wooden
please for all the top tens just go to
any top 10 video and leave the request
there and and my team will pick it up a
little add it to the list
next up mattis paradise if you can't
persuade Jason to go on camera then why
do I need to read your book ok can you
hear the laughing can you hear the Jason
laughing behind there's points for
originality on there but also the hate I
don't know I don't care I don't I'm not
convincing anybody read my book if
that's the reason if that's the go-to
weather Jason comes on camera or not
that makes you want to buy the book or
not then then I almost don't want to
bring Jason on camera because I don't do
well with threats Jer eyes woo you're
over a hundred books sold now hashtag
keep rising yes I didn't do the update
at the top of the show so we're now 117
books sold it's still far far from where
I want to be but yes we crossed a
hundred books sold threshold and Thank
You J rise for bringing that up because
I forgot to mention at the top and I get
that it's a long way away and that it's
hard to buy something nav so that comes
in December you know there are free
bonuses that come alongside and attached
to it you do get immediately but also I
hope that I've given you enough value
right like I hope you know how much is
the book cost 20 bucks I hope that I've
given you more than $20 worth of value
in all of these free YouTube videos that
you consider supporting me and if I've
given you $5,000 with the value maybe
you can buy more than one book right or
ten thousands of the value at that ante
a little bit show a little bit of love
and support and appreciation I'm not
asking for a lot from you guys and I'm
not hard selling anything on my channel
so hopefully that appreciation will come
through and we can get to our 3,000 book
bull Marco Polo waiting for audio book
it's up Marco Polo it is up Marco Polo
I'm excited next up PMA
Reza's congrats heaven I've been
watching you for almost a year now
you're one of my favorite mentoring on
YouTube guy appreciate that feeling the
love I for sure will buy your book don't
know how but I will Virginia from Panama
the tiny worm country with a big heart
in Central America I appreciate that
thank you so much I haven't been the
Panama yet but it's on my list so this
might make it a little bit faster me get
in the Panama thank you for the support
next up a Mervyn Bonanno heroin thanks
for sharing all these information I just
have a question about how does an author
get paid from book sales please provide
one or several examples so I think it
depends on what your model is what your
goal is what your objective is as an
author if you just want to make money
from your book then the best way to do
it is to self publish because you own
the book you own all the rights to it
you keep almost all of the sales comp
you have a little bit of charge for we
own winner when if somebody buys a book
you have processing payments is up but
in general you get everything so money
is your only goal that's the way to do
it if you're going through a publisher
like I did then you may or may not get
in advance so I got a pretty good
advance for first time author but
usually the first time author you
wouldn't expect to get any kind of
advance I wouldn't bank on that and then
you get some kind of percentage of sales
as you go along and I honestly don't
even know what it is 1% 2% I don't know
because most of the book sales are so
meaningless from an off the point of
view in terms of a revenue standpoint
that it's not why I do it like to go
with one publisher because they're gonna
give me a half a point higher than the
other publisher it's not worth it I'd
rather have a publisher who really wants
me to go out there and make a big splash
and have a big impact it will help
market it and promote it and edit it and
all that stuff is much more important
for me so depending on your goals if
money is the only thing you're looking
at just so publish your like what you
may sell less but you'll make more
dollars because you keep everything
where you only get a certain percentage
and again I don't have examples to share
because I don't know what's my own
contract because it's so far from what
I'm thinking about it's not the purpose
of why I'm writing this book so those
are my thoughts
next up Arun Kumar thanks to the video
Evan bro here one of your friends from
India so keep pushing your publisher to
sell your book in India thank you we've
had a number of orders from India but
again I know it's expensive with
shipping I don't know where they're
buying from Amazon
and then shipping it I know it's
expensive so this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna copy and paste this to my
publisher and let them know hey what's
up let's get on Amazon India how long is
this gonna take come on so keep those
coming in if you're not seeing it in
your local market then let me know I'm
gonna keep sending my publisher and
hopefully we can make that happen for
you guys next up John zimba hey I'm from
Zambia how can I get your book I would
check Amazon I don't know if there's
Amazon Zambia how that works where you
normally order stuff online if you do
have a name at Amazon Zambia let me know
I'm gonna I'm gonna send this to my
publisher to write like you're from a
country that I don't know where if
Amazon has a big presence in or not just
keep keep putting in the comments and
I'll send to my publisher and we'll do
our best to apply some pressure
last up shin pay everything to all these
videos just ordered your book time
regards less yes and thank you less and
I actually just made a shout out video
for you this morning I remember making
that just before I left I came here I
made a quick video for you that's
unlisted that is in your inbox so
hopefully you've already seen it by the
time this video comes out so that's it
for today thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate your
support I'd love to know what you think
about the topic at the top which was
about momentum and not accepting no for
an answer and keep pushing through so
leave a comment let me know what you
think if you have questions about my
book the book writing process any of
that leave it down below in the comments
too and I will answer in next week's
video today shout out goes the fairy
Vinc very thank you so much you're
picking up a copy of the book those you
guys watching you want your chance at a
shout out in a future video get a copy
and email in the receipts for those of
you bind but not emailing in we can't
track you we can't send you the bonuses
we can't give you the shoutouts or any
other cool stuff so make sure you email
in your receipts so we can keep track
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon